here are 10 music artists who seem to
have sold their soul to
Satan one Katie Perry Katie whose real
name is Katherine Elizabeth Hudson grew
up as a PK or pastor's kid with two
Evangelical Christian pastors as parents
in her sheltered home she wasn't allowed
to check out rly music artists we knew
about Madonna and Marilyn Manson in my
family because we picked at their
concerts once while handing out
pamphlets at a Manson concert Perry went
inside and to her surprise found it
really interesting and weird I got it
she said it's notable that Katie Perry
shares to have found Marilyn Manson who
was a priest of the Church of Satan
interesting because years later she said
this yeah I mean I released a gospel
record when I was 15 um because I grew
up in uh you know a household where all
I ever did was listen to gospel music
and my parents are both traveling
ministers and so I kind of sang about
you know what was going on in my life at
15 and that's how I got introduced to
the music industry I swear I wanted to
be like the Amy Grand of music yeah but
it didn't work out and so I sold my soul
of the devil Katy Perry is now known to
throw around a lot of satanic ult and
Pagan symbols including references to
Egyptian gods Freemason imagery such as
the checkered board at her Super Bowl
performance snakes which according to
the Bible is a symbol of Satan and
Aliens which actually is a reference to
Demons check out our free documentary on
Aliens disclosed to find out more two
Demi lado this controversial singer
shocked the world when she decided to
get baptized in the Jordan River in
Israel in 2019 but her Christian
conversion didn't seem to have stuck for
very long 3 years later she released an
album called holy F that album cover
shows her lying on a mattress in the
shape of a cross which many Christians
have called Blasphemous in her song Holy
F she even seemed to be suggesting that
she embodies Satan himself like a
serpent in the garden I am truth and I
am Darkness I am an angel I'm a demon
just depends on what you're feeling I'm
the fruit that was forbidden but don't
keep my evil hidden I'm the one she was
afraid of now I'm what your dreams are
are made of the serpent in the garden is
obviously Satan in the Bible the devil
in the form of a snake tempted Eve with
forbidden fruit and the woman said to
the serpent we may eat the fruit of the
Trees of the garden but of the fruit of
the tree which is in the midst of the
garden God has said You shall not eat it
nor shall you touch it lest you die then
the serpent said to the woman you will
not surely die for God knows that in the
day you eat of it your eyes will be
opened and you will be like God knowing
good and evil so when the woman saw that
the tree was good for food that it was
pleasant to the eyes and a tree
desirable to make one wise she took of
its fruit and ate she also gave to her
husband with her and he ate three Prince
the high-pitched singer might have been
mostly known for his hit song I Want To
Be Your Lover but just like Katie Perry
he also seemed to have been vocal about
selling his soul
in his song Dance with the Devil he
sings cunning liar Eternal fire demon
clever promise forever the Curious try
and always die live in fear the devil is
near can you feel his breath pray for
death the Curious try and always die
have no savior have no faith never look
for Heaven's Gate Devil's children no
love inside there is a soul but it has
died Devil's children no love inside
there is a soul but it has died and it
cries and it cries Dance with the Devil
in the pale Moonlight put your arms
around him and hold him tight give up to
the feeling and don't try to fight he
wants your soul and he wants it tonight
Dance with the Devil in the pale
Moonlight put your arms around him and
hold him tight close your eyes to love
and die you know without you I just
wouldn't want to go on in an interview
with Oprah Prince also shared how he has
another person living inside of him
could this be a demon he's invited
in during our conversation the artist
shared a very personal Discovery he's
recently made about himself this is very
interesting recent uh analysis has
proved that there's probably two people
inside of me just like a Gemini and we
haven't determined what sex that other
person is yet did you say I'm not even
sure what sex it is or he or she or is
did you say that yeah I thought I heard
that what I'm getting from you is that
you were very much in touch with both
sides of yourself your masculine and
feminine side oh yeah yeah and always
have been uhhuh it's literally like
another personality you're talking about
well what they seemed to find was that
it was some someone I had created when I
was 5 years old really
mhm for whatever reason I'm not sure yet
but I hope to find out and you found out
that there is another person yeah living
inside you this is turning into a Cil
interview does that person have a name
that we could call that's what's that's
what is so interesting to me is that I
um I think that that's why I changed my
name I think that's who I am now I yeah
I very much feel divorced from Prince
you really do yes just what message are
these demonic beings communicating
through Prince besides sexual perversion
Prince's song Night 1899 appears to be
about refusing to repent in the end
times it is stated I was dreaming when I
wrote this so forgive me if it goes
astray but when I woke up this morning I
could have sworn it was Judgment Day
Prince goes on to sing about the coming
destruction and how he didn't even care
and he's going to keep on partying
through 1999 into 2000 Prince is
declaring that he's going to party until
Judgment Day through 1999 1999 seems to
be a slightly veiled reference to the
coming Antichrist Kingdom when looking
at the front cover of Prince's album
1999 in the middle of the name Prince we
see Prince in the revolution written
backwards as taught by alester Crowley
we also see that the P for Prince is
also an upside down flame when this
album is inverted we see more to the
picture that at first glance doesn't
meet the eye now we can see 666 the
Number of the Antichrist with a phallic
pointing down Prince backwards is made
into evil e b i l and then the upside
down P denotes fiery destruction in 2016
Prince was found dead in an elevator his
death seemed very suspicious to many
listen to what CEO of Epic Records La
Reed says in an interview one thing that
you know kind of spooked me about it all
was um here has a song called uh let's
go crazy and it says don't let the
elevator bring us down one time when I
was with him privately he said you know
what the elevator is right I said no
what's the elevator he said well the
elevator is the devil right it scared me
you I don't like to talk like that but
he said that and so for me it was like
really haunting when I read that he was
found in an
[Music]
elevator ET confirmed the iconic artist
was found dead in an elevator on
Thursday La Reed says he believed Prince
to have been in good health did he have
health problems that I don't know right
what I know is that um he was really
healthc conscious he was a vegan he
didn't abuse alcohol I didn't know of
him abusing drugs uh he worked out you
know so you know that that also really
concerned me because it made me think
that wow so you mean you do all these
things to take care of yourself and you
die so young or Beyonce if if you think
that Prince's extra personage that he
has inside of him was just him playing
around with an alra ego listen to what
Beyonce said in an interview with bet
and I remember right before I performed
I raised my hands up and it was kind of
the first time I I felt something else
come into me and I knew that was going
to be my coming out
night and um
I'm really kind of shy and not really
shy but more reserved and um nothing
like
[Music]
Sasha but I guess I wouldn't be very
entertaining on the stage so Sasha comes
out and she's
fearless you know she can she can do
things that I cannot do when I'm in
rehearsal I mean I can try but then it
just doesn't happen I can sing notes and
sing Strong and do all these things that
when I'm just by myself I can't do so
like when you're getting ready to go on
stage and perform is Sasha Fierce when
did she show up usually when I hear the
crowd when I put on my stilettos um when
like the the moment right before when
you're nervous and and that other thing
kind of takes over for you uhhuh and I
it's no different from anyone else I
feel like we all kind of have that that
thing that takes over when Beyonce is
again one of those celebrities who grew
up Christian seems to have lost sight of
their religious upbringing even going as
far as embracing satanic and Pagan
symbolism here the singer is seen
dressed up in a motorcycle costume
hinting at the goat of baffet a symbol
of Satan she tends to throw up the
Illuminati triangles a lot and of course
she's dressed up as a sun goddess or has
had references to the Sun God on
numerous occasions in the anian days the
Sun God was also known as Bale which
again is just another version of a god
that is technically Satan during her
2013 halftime show performance two faces
of the Gemini twins showed up in
Babylonian astronomy the Stars Pollock
and Castor were known as the great twins
their names were legal era and mes Luma
a meaning the mighty king and the one
who has risen from the underworld both
names are titles of nural a major
Babylonian God of plague and pestilence
who was King of the underworld I'm sure
you can figure out who the king of the
underworld is supposed to be five
Rolling Stones who remembers the song
Sympathy for the Devil these guys were
not shy about who their inspiration came
from the lyrics are as follows please
allow me to introduce myself I'm a man
of wealth and taste I've been around for
a long long year stole many in man's
soul and faith and I was around when
Jesus Christ had his moment of doubt and
in pain made D sure that pilot washed
his hands and sealed his fate pleased to
meet you hope you guess my name what's
puzzling you is the nature of my game
just as every cop is a criminal and all
the Sinners Saints as heads is Tails
just call me Lucifer cuz I'm in need of
some restraint so if you meet me have
some courtesy have some sympathy and
some taste use all your well-learned
politeness or I'll lay your soul in
waste according to genius this song is
sung in firsters form with Nick Jagger
playing no one else but San himself now
supposedly this song was written about
communism and Stalin and various other
major events in the world that could
have been seen as works of the devil but
is that the only meaning of the song
drop a comment below and let us know
what you think six Billy ish I remember
when her new song all the good girls go
to hell was released back in 2020
millions of people waited for her the
premiere on YouTube to watch the music
video as soon as it came out currently
it has over 230 million views what's
crazy is the connection between this
music video and the one for her song
bury a friend which are both part of the
Same album and bar a friend Billy ish
sings about selling her soul to the
devil the debt I owe got to sell my soul
cuz I can't say no no I can't say no
then my limbs all froze and my eyes want
clothes in the music video for this song
in which she sings that she has got to
sell her soul because she has a debt she
owes you can see her getting pulled down
by some hands and then getting syringes
stuck in her back and there's even black
veins growing then on the Same album
there's the song all the gir girls go to
hell and this music video starts off
with the syringes in her back as a
continuation of bar a friends music
video but now demon wings grow out of
her back after which she falls from the
sky just like Satan in the Bible got
cast out of heaven and war broke out in
heaven Michael and his angels fought
with the dragon and the dragon and his
angels fought but they did not Prevail
nor was a place found for them in heaven
any longer so the Great Dragon was cast
out that old serpent called the devil
and Satan who deceived the whole world
he was cast to the Earth and his angels
were cast out with him check out what
sings in all the good girls go to hell
all the good girls go to hell cuz even
God herself has enemies and once the
water starts to rise and Heaven's out of
sight she'll want the devil on her team
my Lucifer's lonely there's nothing left
to save now my God's going to owe me
there's nothing left to save
now my lucier is
lonely seven Robert Johnson this singer
songwriter who was considered the master
of Blues quickly Rose to Fame in the
early 1900s after he went to the
crossroads to sell his soul to Satan
Johnson simply sucked at playing the
guitar but that all changed after his
experience with handing his life over to
the devil eight young boy NBA in an
interview with complex the rapper shares
how the music industry is demonic you
said
that music like in terms of getting paid
it's a the biggest s only all your R
because a it's a it's
a the Mind industry that I chose to be a
part of so like I accept that
I but don't a d at the same time you got
to understand us me as
entertainment self-destruction too M cuz
I a know
time you know some
why who do you think young boy NBA is
referring to when he says that they're
using him as entertainment drop a
comment below and let us know nine Ellie
Golding the famous British pop singer
has mostly had a pretty clean image
except that in an interview with billbo
she said this I kind of get possessed by
the devil when I'm performing I like
headbanged so hard that I got concussion
which is funny and then of course we see
Ellie rocking some Illuminati symbolism
with the triangle and the snake as a
reference to Satan and Pearl Jam
Triangle shirt and a 666 shirt and then
we haven't even talked about her
official logo yet that's all over her
merch 10 lil Nas x one of the most
outrageously satanic artist lately is
Lil Nas X I mean he has a music video in
which he's literally twerking on top of
Satan the music video for his song
Montero call me by your name starts off
with a snake gliding toward little Nas X
sitting under a tree Garden of Eden with
the serpent Vibes anyone according to
Time Magazine the satanic snake like
figure that tries to tempt L Nas X is
Lilith which is the name for the Gnostic
version of Lucifer nosism is a sect that
stems from the second century which
attempts to flip various Concepts in the
Bible upside down one of those Concepts
simply explained is that Satan is
actually good and brings Enlightenment
God according to narcissism is the enemy
so this is what Lil Nas X is portraying
in this video which he expresses by
twerking on the lap of this so-called
Good Devil okay so back to the Montero
music video after lth or Satan seems to
have successfully tempted Lil Nas X we
see the singer being taken up to dis Sky
to meet some kind of angel or a demon
and after that he's cast down to Hell
just like Satan was cast out of heaven
and after that the singer looks like a
demon himself while this scene is taking
place he's singing the following call me
what you want call me when you need call
me in the morning I'll be on the way
call me when you want call me when you
need call me out by your name I'll be on
the way like and who do you think Lil
Nas X is saying we should call the music
video wraps up with the artist making
sexual moves on Satan and then growing
demon wings himself so what do you think
have these 10 musicians sold their soul
to Satan and what about this former
heavy metal band member teimo Hoffman he
was on his way to fame and says that
Satan asked him to sell his soul but he
didn't accept the devil's offer want to
know why watch this video right here and
find out for yourself
[Music]